el día 24 de abril del 2023 no fue un
día cualquiera fue una jornada que pasó
a la historia por primera vez en muchos
muchísimos siglos china dejó
Oficialmente de ser el país con más
habitantes del mundo ese día la ONU
declaró que en la siguiente
actualización de sus estimaciones
demográficas la India le arrebataría a
China el primero de los puestos en el
ranking de los países con mayor
población es decir que la India ya es a
todas luces el país más poblado de todo
el planeta según Naciones Unidas más de
1.425 millones de personas viven hoy por
hoy en la India una cifra que como veis
se espera crezca hasta casi los
1.700 millones para mediados de siglo
estos que veis en pantalla serán los
nuevos Gigantes demográficos y como veis
a la cabeza de todos ellos y por mucha
diferencia estará la India una economía
emergente con un discreto pero activo
Arsenal nuclear y un peso político que
en los últimos años ha comenzado a
despegar
[Música]
amigos amigas la India quiere
capitalizar su estatus como el país más
poblado de la tierra y por eso ahora
está buscando por ejemplo tener un
puesto permanente en el consejo de
seguridad de las Naciones Unidas ahora
bien Si en lugar de mirar al exterior
nos concentramos en el interior del país
nos vamos a encontrar con realidades muy
distintas por ejemplo el sistema de
castas de este país es una especie de
misterio popular se sabe mucho de su
existencia pero no tanto de su
funcionamiento ni tampoco de sus
consecuencias porque sí en cierta forma
el sistema de castas sigue existiendo
por mucho que hace ya décadas que la ley
lo pusiera en la Diana y eso ha hecho
que en visualpolitik nos hagamos unas
cuantas preguntas Hasta qué punto sigue
operando el sistema de castas cómo
funciona exactamente en la India moderna
puede ser este fenómeno una especie de
talón de Aquiles capaz de evitar que el
país más superpoblado del mundo pueda
prosperar pues queridos amigos y amigas
en este nuevo vídeo de visualpolitik
vamos a buscar todas las respuestas
arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
últimamente la India se está poniendo de
moda y ya comienza a protagonizar
grandes titulares como estos 11 de abril
de 2022 la India quiere un papel clave
en la cadena de suministro a medida que
las empresas se mudan de China 30 de
abril de 2023 porque todo el mundo en el
ámbito empresarial adora la India en
estos momentos 21 de junio 2023 el
legendario inversor en mercados
emergentes Mark mobius conocido por sus
opiniones alcistas sobre china se fija
ahora en la India además esta
superpotencia emergente cuenta con un
sistema político relativamente estable
desde el año 2004 hasta ahora Solo han
ejercido la jefatura del gobierno dos
primeros ministros Man moján sing y
narendramovic del Congreso Nacional
indio y el partido popular indio
respectivamente es decir que más allá de
lo más o menos controvertidas que puedan
ser estas figuras políticas Lo cierto es
que el sistema de gobierno parece
bastante estable y predecible
dos ingredientes muy apreciados por todo
inversor extranjero
Así que en otras palabras la India
parece tener todos los rasgos de una
potencia en ascenso una economía en
marcha un Arsenal militar creciente un
rol geopolítico clave entre occidente y
Oriente y además una relación
razonablemente buena con Washington con
Moscú e incluso con Pekín al menos todo
lo buenas que podrían ser si tenemos en
cuenta los históricos recelos entre los
dos gigantes asiáticos sin embargo no sé
hay algo que no suena raro lo de querer
ser una potencia en ascenso que además
aspire a lograr el mismo éxito económico
que tuvieron los dragones asiáticos y
luego al mismo tiempo mantener un
sistema que clasifica la población Según
a que casta o linaje pertenezca no casa
nada pero que nada bien no os parece
Pero qué son exactamente las castas Pues
básicamente hablamos Por así decirlo de
la madre de todas las burocracias un
orden social del que resulta muy difícil
escapar una forma de organización social
muy antigua Y es que podemos rastrear su
existencia hasta 3000 años antes de
Cristo Pues bien este sistema consiste
en dividir a las personas en diferentes
grupos sociales conocidos Como castas y
es hereditario Es decir uno si nace en
una casta Por lo general permanece en
ella por el resto de su vida
originalmente las castas se definieron a
través del varna una palabra en lugar
sánscrita que se traduce como color
Aunque en este caso no se refiere a la
piel sino a la clasificación social una
clasificación social que
tradicionalmente condicionaba toda tu
vida los trabajos que podías desempeñar
con quién te podías emparentar tu rol en
la sociedad etcétera etcétera de esta
forma se intenta O al menos se intentaba
estructurar a toda la sociedad los
hindules dividen a las personas según
sus vidas pasadas en la cima están los
brahmanes que son los sacerdotes y los
eruditos luego los chatrias o los
gobernantes y los soldados debajo de
ellos están los Bahía esto es los
mercaderes y los comerciantes y luego
los sudras los trabajadores por último
los dalias que son Los Intocables y que
son considerados impuros y sucios son
indignos de pertenecer a cualquier casta
por tradición son El eslabón más bajo el
caso es que todas las personas que nacen
en una casta particular tienen ya un rol
asignado en vida social
es decir que se enfrentan a escalones
sociales y económicos ya predeterminados
y ojo porque hablamos de una
clasificación que aparte de los cuatro
grandes cupos en realidad está dividida
en cerca de 3.000 castas y casi
25.000 subcastas y luego están las
tribus que vienen a ser otra
clasificación y luego las personas que
se quedan fuera de este sistema y que
forman lo que se conoce como Los
Intocables el estrato más bajo de toda
la sociedad personas que estaban
obligadas a realizar trabajos
considerados como sucios o impuros y que
eran frecuentemente excluidas
socialmente por supuesto como ya os
podéis imaginar semejantes engranajes
sociales tienen un coste de oportunidad
enorme durante siglos este sistema ha
limitado el ascenso social como ningún
otro afortunadamente hoy ya está en
declive aunque como veremos la sociedad
India todavía no ha conseguido Li por
completo de él de hecho para muchos
sigue siendo un grave problema para las
aspiraciones de la India pero sabéis que
para entender toda esta historia tenemos
que echar la vista ligeramente hacia
atrás tenemos que ver cómo y Cuándo
comenzó a combatirse este perverso
sistema Así que vamos con ello
dicho al hecho
queridos amigos durante la vigencia del
rach británico los propios agentes
europeos incorporaron el sistema de
castas indio en su sistema de gobierno
lo utilizaban por ejemplo para asignar
los diferentes cargos en las
instituciones locales Claro que hacia
1920 los propios británicos comenzaron a
limitar su uso en parte para frenar el
creciente descontento hacia la corona
lógicamente qué queréis que os diga eso
de nacer pobre y no poder tener
esperanzas en mejorar tu situación o
tener que resignarte a tener una vida
muy similar a la de tus padres pues como
que no es plato de buen gusto para nadie
pero eso fue solo el comienzo cuando la
India logró por fin sellar su
independencia se planteó una
constitución que fue de frente contra
este sistema de castas su Artículo 15
decía exactamente el estado no
discriminará ningún ciudadano únicamente
por motivos de religión Rafa casta sexo
lugar de nacimiento o cualquiera de
ellos la construcción de la nueva nación
por fin liberada del colonialismo inglés
fue liderada en su mayor parte por las
castas de más alto Rango las cuales
tienen el rol precisamente de conducir
los asuntos de estado pero pese a ello
ya lo veis en la propia Constitución
señalaron al sistema de castas
prohibiendo al Estado que tomara
decisiones en base hasta terrible
clasificación social un primer paso para
acabar con ella El problema es que esta
es una de esas cosas que es más fácil de
decir que hacer
desde entonces gobierno tras gobierno
las autoridades indias han tratado de
desmontar la rígida estratificación
social que vivía el país en 1955 por
ejemplo se promulgó la ley de
intocabilidad que reglamentaba como
delito la discriminación por casta en
espacios laborales o educativos en 1976
amplió el alcance de esta ley y se
rebautizó como la ley de protección de
los Derechos civiles y así se fueron
aprobando un popurrí de nuevas normas
leyes y disposiciones hasta que en 1979
se produjo un punto de inflexión el
establecimiento de la comisión de clases
social y educativamente atrasadas o como
popularmente se le conoce la comisión
manda
[Música]
esta comisión le debe su nombre a babu
vindesbari prasat mandal un político
originario de una de las castas más
poderosas del país que recibió la misión
del gobierno del Primer Ministro morargi
de sai de elaborar un informe que
analizara la situación de las castas y
esbozará un paquete de políticas para
poder revertir de cuajo toda esta enorme
estratificación social Pues bien el
informe se terminó en
1980 y fue presentado a la entonces
primera ministra Indira Gandhi lo que
abrió un feroz debate político y social
el informe básicamente consideraba que
pese a todas las prohibiciones legales
el sistema de castas seguía en pie
clasificando y regulando la vida de
decenas y decenas cientos de millones de
indios además denunciaba que por culpa
de las castas muchos grupos sociales
habían quedado terriblemente atrás
condenados a vivir en la más abyecta
pobreza y ojo porque no hablamos de poca
gente
[Música]
según este mismo informe las personas
que formaban parte de las castas o las
clases más bajas y por tanto eran las
más perjudicadas por un sistema que de
hecho las despreciaba sumaban cerca del
50% de toda la población del país pues
bien para intentar revertir esta
situación la comisión mandal hizo
algunas recomendaciones Como por ejemplo
incidir en los sistemas de cupos y
reservar al menos el 27% de los trabajos
públicos y las plazas educativas para
personas que formarán parte de las
clases sociales atrasadas que no
estuvieran ya protegidas El problema es
que el coste de semejante plan y sobre
todo la resistencia de diferentes
sectores políticos a la hora de aceptar
como válido este informe retrasaron la
adopción de las diferentes
recomendaciones que se hacían Y así fue
hasta que en 1989 el gobierno indio
promulgó la ley de castas y tribus
registradas endureciendo aún más las
medidas contra esta especie de clasismo
social además en 1990 el gobierno
comenzó a implementar la recomendaciones
de la comisión mandal algo que por
cierto desató grandes protestas por lo
que se consideraba un claro atropello a
los principios meritocráticos del Estado
Indio
[Música]
al final las cosas se torcieron tanto
que el propio Primer Ministro terminó
renunciando en noviembre de ese mismo
año lo que hizo que se reconsiderara el
sistema de cupos y reservas pero amigos
creéis que ahí se terminó la
controversia pues no nada de nada la
polémica llegó a la Corte Suprema de la
India en 1992 este órgano determinó que
se creara la Comisión Nacional de clases
atrasadas y que se avanzará en las
medidas dictadas por el informe de la
comisión mandal favoreciendo Eso sí las
medidas de cortes social y educativo
desde entonces la Comisión Nacional de
clases atrasadas funciona como un
organismo ejecutivo a través del cual
cada gobierno canaliza sus medidas
contra el sistema de castas es decir que
el gobierno indio Lleva años luchando
contra este sistema La pregunta es
realmente Ha logrado erradicarlo Qué
impacto siguen teniendo las castas en la
India Por qué muchos analistas piensan
que aún pueden ser una gran traba para
El despegue económico de este país pues
bien veámoslo
[Música]
las castas en el siglo XXI
ya lo habéis visto en los últimos años
todos los gobiernos han tratado de
luchar contra el sistema de castas pero
lo cierto Es que este en cierta forma
aún sobrevive parece que 34 o 5 décadas
no han sido suficientes para echar abajo
una tradición con miles de años de
antigüedad
[Música]
en 2011 por ejemplo el censo social y
económico todavía mostraba que cuatro de
cada diez indios estaban clasificados
como parte de las clases más bajas y no
solo eso luego las castas más bajas y
las tribus registradas que son grupos
que también son en mayor o menor medida
desfavorecidos y discriminados
socialmente sumaban casi otro 30% de la
población solo las castas generales son
aquellas que no sufren prejuicios o
tienen privilegios y como podéis ver en
2011 apenas suponían el 30,7% de la
población era y sigue siendo el grupo
privilegiado a Costa en gran medida del
resto del país
pero no Tenemos que irnos tan atrás
evidentemente las cosas ya no están tan
mal pero en 2021 este sistema seguía
teniendo por ejemplo mucha incidencia en
la pobreza
a nivel de salud nutrición años de
escolarización saneamientos o vivienda
lo miremos por donde lo miremos
pertenecer a una casta o a una tribu de
nivel bajo o a Los Intocables sigue
siendo sinónimo de muchos más problemas
y peores condiciones de vida es decir la
brecha no se ha cerrado y si no se ha
cerrado es porque la influencia de este
sistema todavía persiste un total 5 de
cada seis personas en situación de
pobreza multidimensional en la India
viven en hogares encabezados por una
persona perteneciente a una tribu
registrada una casta registrada u otra
clase atrasada y ojo Porque si la
población India supera los 1.400
millones de habitantes hablamos de que
cerca de mil millones de personas lo
tienen más difícil que el resto por una
simple cuestión de linaje y no me
refiero al patrimonio de las familias
sino su capacidad para escalar puestos
profesionales sociales e incluso
políticos conforme a sus propios méritos
de locos y sabéis que justo aquí es
cuando llegamos a la parte clave de este
vídeo pese a todos los avances logrados
por la creciente persecución del
gobierno el principal problema que sigue
causando toda esta estratificación
social tiene que ver precisamente con la
pérdida de capital humano que conlleva y
no olvidemos que el capital humano es
una variable absolutamente indispensable
para que un país logre desarrollarse
queridos amigos amigas podemos estar
hablando de un coste de oportunidad
gigantesco tanto para los indios como
para el resto del mundo atentos
[Música]
el potencial en las sombras
cuando echamos un vistazo al sistema
educativo indio lo primero con lo que
nos encontramos en primaria y secundaria
Es que la diferencia entre los
diferentes grupos sociales que están
bien bastante notable tres cuartas
partes de los estudiantes forman parte
de Los Intocables o de las casas y las
tribus desfavorecidas socialmente lo
cual tiene sentido las familias más
pobres siguen teniendo más hijos y ya
hemos visto que el sistema de castas
sigue teniendo mucha incidencia en los
datos de pobreza Pues bien sea como sea
el problema es que esto también
condiciona su rendimiento educativo los
niños de estas familias tienen tasas de
fracasos con la más altas lo que
evidentemente supone un enorme coste de
oportunidad sí es verdad y los datos han
mejorado de cada tras década pero
Todavía existen diferencias
significativas y si nos vamos a los
niveles superiores las diferencias son
más abultadas Y es que amigos aquí nos
encontramos con dos caras totalmente
diferentes
[Aplausos]
por un lado la India Es según la UNESCO
el país que más cantidad de estudiantes
tiene en Secundaria como podéis ver
prácticamente dobla a China y eso es una
gran noticia una población más formada
suele traducirse en mejores puestos de
trabajo y un desarrollo más rápido y no
solo eso la India también es uno de los
países del Mundo donde los estudiantes
universitarios se inclinan más por las
carreras de ciencias tecnología
ingeniería y matemáticas sin embargo por
otra parte por culpa del sistema de
castas es muy probable que cerca de la
mitad de todos estos estudiantes de
secundaria que hemos mencionado no
pueden acceder a estudios universitarios
o a una formación profesional de calidad
lo que supone un enorme desperdicio de
Talento
[Música]
de hecho este dichoso sistema de
clasificación social sigue tan arraigado
que sus efectos incluso han llegado a
los mismísimos Estados Unidos y no a
cualquier parte se sospecha que incluso
empieza alguna incidencia en el
mismísimo silicon Valley un momento
pensáis que nos hemos vuelto locos
Estados Unidos casta Pues sí fijaos
porque eso es exactamente lo que explica
noticias como estas los ingenieros de la
India han prosperado en silicon Valley
también lo ha hecho su sistema de castas
como las grandes tecnológicas están
importando el legado de castas de la
India a silicon Valley el año pasado un
graduado Dalí de itt bombay presentó una
demanda en Estados Unidos contra Cisco
systems y dos de sus compañeros diciendo
que había sufrido discriminación basada
en la casta vale puede que quizás sean
solo un par de casos aislados o quizás
no porque lo cierto Es que en los
últimos años docenas de ingenieros
indios que trabajan en el extranjero
sobre todo en Estados Unidos han llevado
este tema a los tribunales lo que bueno
no sé como mínimo podemos decir que
resulta muy significativo de hecho esta
exportación cultural tan digamos
particular Podría tener su origen en los
institutos indios de administración y en
los institutos indios de tecnología
estas instituciones fueron crea das por
el gobierno indio en los 60 y hoy son la
crem de la crem del sistema
universitario Pues bien Pese a que
cuentan con un sistema de cupos para que
accedan a algunos estudiantes de las
castas más desfavorecidas Lo cierto es
que mayoritariamente están copados por
los grupos sociales más digamos
privilegiados
amigos amigas el sistema de castas está
formalmente perseguido desde los 70 pero
a pesar de ello sigue teniendo una
enorme influencia en la sociedad India
las familias de linaje más bajo conforme
a este sistema tienden a ser más pobres
sus hijos tienen mayores tasas de
fracaso escolar y muchas más
dificultades para que les contraten en
un buen trabajo es Por así decirlo una
mancha que los acompaña de por vida por
supuesto esto puede provocar muchos
problemas desigualdad frustración e
incluso con el tiempo también
conflictividad social como para no
Parece Mentira pero este todavía es un
tema que en la India se tienen que tomar
muy en serio pero llegamos hasta aquí la
pregunta ahora es para ti qué os parece
este peculiar sistema de clasificación
social por qué creéis que ningún
gobierno Ha logrado erradicarlo que
tendrían que hacer para acabar con él de
una vez por todas como siempre déjanos
tus impresiones abajo en los comentarios
y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante podéis darle al botón de
like y suscribiros a visualpolitik si es
que aún no lo habéis hecho que no me lo
creo Muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]